do you guys think that men should have
an opinion on abortion because we
constantly hear my body my choice men
shouldn't have an opinion on this
but today we have a doctor here who
probably knows more about abortion than
most people and imagine doctor
um so should should men have an opinion
on abortion I I think I think yes I
think yeah yeah for sure yeah 100 what
do you guys think it's half it's it's a
piece of you it's a piece of me like you
know what I mean what do you guys think
on the couch
um I I actually think now no no I
actually think that it's the woman's
Choice yeah okay she said can you have
an opinion
but it's the same thing like what I said
about women having the um the final say
if a guy still has a part saying having
sex and a guy should still have Parts
saying if they have an abortion or not a
guy has a part say whether you remove a
condom or not whether women feel like a
guy should have a say or not a guy has a
say because they're short it's your
organs we're all talking about um do you
think do you think a guy should be able
to veto an abortion so let's say let's
say you got pregnant and you won an
abortion the father of the kid could he
have a say in it yeah like if the father
so if he said no and you wanted it would
you go with like do you think he should
be able to legally say you can't have an
abortion oh no no but it's that's that's
where that's where some people that's
where you were talking about
accountability and responsibility kind
of comes from because if you're gonna
have unprotected sex with somebody
it kind of some people obviously if
you're not in a relationship you're not
in a relationship but you need to kind
of still choose who you're having sex
with wisely because you need to be able
to know the person you're having sex
with you can still have that kind of
conversation and come to an
understanding and stuff like that you
have to kind at the end of the day
there's only yay or nay you have to come
to an agreement so okay but so you would
you personally would take his opinion
into account yeah
legally you still think you should have
no say no I'm not saying legally he
shouldn't have no say no I'm sorry I'm
asking like what what would it look like
so if he he gets to say what say does he
get it's I it's all to do pros and cons
really are we ready to have a baby are
you financially ready to have a baby am
I financially ready to have a baby
so I'm saying two people yeah the woman
says I want an abortion he says that's
my kid I don't want you to have one
should he legally have any rights in the
situation I'm asking you
um
see there I don't know there you would
have actually I think legally I I
couldn't answer that I'd like to be fair
because okay but you think they guys
should or shouldn't no so sorry so I
think he should not have a say so it
should be that I am I know you don't
agree with it okay I do I do I do but I
do think it is the woman's Choice it is
the body of the woman and yeah I just I
think that is the way I think otherwise
you're just going to be going back and
forth on who say should it be
um and it's just you're never gonna get
it my thing is if we're gonna make it
equal why don't we actually make it
equal that's right why don't so why
don't men get to like sign off on child
support yeah personally person in
Pearl's world it would all be banned but
my question is like why why don't the
pro-choice people give men an out
because we give women an out because for
the child well can I just say
um if if I do think that they should
have a say legally but the but the the
the only reason that I think that the
only way that you can is if you're gonna
be legally put in a stop to me
getting a boss getting an abortion okay
then legally you have to be involved 50
legally because if you stop me from
getting this abortion and then run off
and leave me with this baby
mate that's not okay so if that that is
the only way I would see that it would
be okay Legally Legally yes okay but if
they have okay so you you actually kind
of want it to be equal in a way yeah and
you think he should be able to sign off
on child support okay okay why did I say
something yeah go ahead I think
um just the the the the process process
of making a baby it's already an unequal
thing that woman has to carry a baby and
go through the go through the the nine
months ten months pregnancy and then you
know have the baby so my opinion man can
have uh men can persuade the woman or
say whatever based on the situation the
women decide
on the final yeah the final second okay
and you would not be for them being able
to sign off on child support
so if women have the final say which is
fine right but could men then say I
don't if you don't want to be a mother
then I don't have to be a father and if
you keep the baby when he doesn't want
it he can sign off on child support
uh personally as a modern woman I mean
if I chose to have the baby and he
doesn't want to I don't mind right sign
off sign off it you know I I would raise
the baby myself if I chose to okay yeah
okay I'm curious why don't you think men
should have an opinion on it
all right so my mom was a very proud
woman okay and she never received any
child support from her I didn't even
realize you said that I was asking her
oh I'm sorry do you want me to stop uh
it's okay can I ask her and then I'll
ask you next go ahead uh can you why
don't you think men should have an
opinion on abortion
um because the woman's body changes so
much
um it's nine to ten months and of being
pregnant and after you have been
pregnant your body will never be the
same so first of all your body's change
forever that's one thing that I don't
think a man has the right to uh
challenge that really
um and the second thing is that
is like more of the broader discussion
of women's rights that like
statistically
uh women has less rights than men what
rights don't we have I mean we earn less
I mean this because we don't do as hard
of jobs we do no we don't yes we do we
do did you build the building next door
go be a plumber go be an electrician
okay the power grids the oil rigs go so
this is this is a massive this is a
massive discussion and I'm more than
happy to start it but uh they're hiring
there's an oil wreck but I mean women
has they have they have been personal I
mean
servants for men in homes for years and
years and years it is another service
just men protected them oh just a second
so and abuse them as well yeah yeah I
mean they also get they also died for
women by going to war and protecting us
it wasn't for women it was for their
country no it was for women women
it was for the government too but women
still got to live in that Society while
not defending it yeah but that's because
we've had this discussion before we've
spoken about men being physically
stronger so that's why they've gone into
fight
correct correct but you don't think we
should thank them that's a privilege oh
we're not saying that but when the young
lady's talking about the body and and
then you know I'm saying I'll let you
continue thank you
um so basically it hasn't been the
woman's choice of not
becoming a doctor becoming a lawyer I
mean get it I mean inheriting property
that hasn't been the or I mean to not
have that right hasn't been the woman's
Choice up until like
um later in time so I feel like we're
kind of hanging
on the back are a little bit and now
women are picking up they are becoming
Prime Ministers and they are you know
they are doctors and lawyers but it
takes time and I feel that I mean
statistically now in the world women has
less rights
well I would say that's not true too we
have more rights so like then you can
start to compare I mean thinking about
women in America how many women are in
office how many women women
becoming more equal like I think we're a
good chunk of Congress now
um I don't know what percent off the top
of my head but women don't want to do
the hardest jobs how do you know because
we don't there's no barriers stopping us
and we don't do them have you spoken to
these women yeah actually you'd be
surprised I probably talked to more
women in a lifetime than any of you have
um
yeah people I mean women to listen to
women who say that they they interview
I've interviewed them in the trades we
just interviewed them last week that's
what I'm saying women do not apply for
these jobs women do not apply for the
hardest job women
I would say I would say the hardest jobs
oil rigs I would say Plumbing
electricity I would say building
buildings how about being in US isn't
that I would say that is I would say I
would say what's harder as a brain
surgeon which more men are
hmm I mean okay so a really interesting
thing is that I
um
I've learned that chefs there's more
male chefs as a occupation then female
chefs but in the home it's usually the
woman that cooks right in my mind
actually but
um but like
so when you
when you sort of come to a certain level
that there's more I don't know like
um
prestige in that job then then you know
it's it's a man but because men compete
for it I think that's our role that's
our role in the society like why man has
more what is it cholesterol the for the
muscle oh
to build muscles you know they're made
for doing these um building house or you
know they go out to hunt these kind of
jobs that's what they are made for and
women women are more caring yeah right
but it would it would make more sense
that they're paid more if they make up
the majority of workplace deaths so
they're doing the more dangerous hard
jobs I'd imagine there's a payout for
that as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick-Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible